why do you think tattoos are a reflex
any woman that is obsessed with drawing
all over her body there's something
wrong with her I've never met a woman
that's heavily tattooed that didn't have
something wrong with it and tattoos are
totally different it's a masculine trait
right like throughout history men have
tattooed themselves you know it's a
tribal sort of experience for some it's
a write a passage for some it has a lot
to do with culture and what they believe
in but tattooing the female body hasn't
hasn't been as common as it is in modern
times it's not that uncommon to see a
beautiful woman covered in tattoos and
it's to me that's the same thing as
putting bumper stickers all over a
Lamborghini men in my experience want
debt free tattoo free virgins when a
woman's tatted up it shows that she's
done something with her past that isn't
that particularly favorable you know
it's like this guy this guy this guy
this guy this guy this guy because
realistically it's mostly guys you know
doing the tattoo work on their bodies
and I know several tattoo artists and
the vast majority of them have intimate
experiences with these women too at the
same time